[Music]
the french empire was one of the most
powerful in human history at its height
it controlled almost 10 percent of the
world's land area from southeast asia to
us to africa the country we today
associate with baguettes and cinema was
a dominant global power and that was
particularly true in africa france
oversaw territory spanning 17 modern day
nations from morocco to the congo
under the banner of a civilizing mission
france oversaw brutal occupations that
engorged the wealth of the empire and
left a terrible legacy for ordinary
africans marked by slavery extraction
and murder and today france's empire in
africa is still around in a streamlined
more profitable and even more
exploitative form
let me explain
in the aftermath of the second world war
there was a wave of de-colonial
movements sweeping across africa and
asia and the french humiliated by their
defeat and occupation at the hands of
the nazis were eager to maintain their
empire so they responded to revolts in
algeria indochina and madagascar with
brutal reprisals maintaining foreign
holdings became increasingly difficult
by 1960 france was forced to grant
independence to almost all its colonies
but something really important happened
in africa
basically the leadership of france
decided to keep their empire in western
and central africa intact in everything
but name
the plan was simple when an african
country gained its independence it was
made to sign a so-called cooperation
agreement with france which would
outline the nature of the relations
moving forward in exchange for french
foreign aid african countries were
required to give france rights over
natural resources allow france to
maintain troops in their territory
indefinitely and most importantly keep
these countries currencies linked to
france's currency the frank instead of
having their own currency they were to
use the frank of the financial community
of africa what is now called the cfa
franc
the french framed these cooperation
agreements as a choice but they were
also clear about the consequences of
defiance when the leader of guinea a
socialist named sakuture rejected the
cooperation agreement with france and
declared that he preferred to be poor in
freedom than rich in slavery the french
government decided to make an example of
him they cut all foreign aid to guinea
and did everything they could to
destabilize the government they launched
a secret campaign to print fake guinean
banknotes and flood the country with
them
one french spy later bragged the
operation was a total success guinea's
economy already very weak never fully
recovered the french said that these
countries existed within the so-called
french community but the policy would
come to be known more widely as friends
of freak it was about having the former
colonies in a position that was
maximally advantageous to french
interests
many of the first generation of
post-colonial leaders in former french
colonies had essentially been installed
by the french they spoke french had
spent time in france and were well
integrated with french elites
jacques vocart a french diplomat oversaw
french relations with africa for almost
30 years and built a huge web of client
relationships with african leaders using
corruption and covert operations to make
them loyal subordinates when local
political orders were threatened the
french weren't afraid to protect their
hand-picked dictators since 1960
france has invaded africa more than 50
times
look at the central african country of
gabon as one example gabon is
particularly important to france because
it has a huge supply of oil and an even
bigger supply of uranium among the
african colonies gabon was historically
one of the very closest to france in
1967 a man named omar bongo became
gabon's president soon turning the
country into a one-party dictatorship
and bongo was intimate with france he
had been appointed after flying to paris
for what was basically a job interview
with the president
so under bongo france and gabon enjoyed
a relationship that benefited both sets
of elites
gaobon's oil was pumped by the french
state-owned oil company elf and its
uranium went right into france's arsenal
of nuclear weapons in return france
subsidized gabon's budget especially the
parts that flowed into the pockets of
omar bongo and his family at one point
bongo was worth over 130 million dollars
gabon meanwhile remained poor and
underdeveloped under bongo it had one of
the highest infant mortality rates in
the world
instead of investing in the gabonese
economy bongo spent state funds on
influencing french politics in his favor
banker along the campaigns of central
future french presidents
even today france keeps troops in the
country to support gabon's current ruler
who happens to be omar bongo's son
and somehow gabon is actually one of the
happier stories other countries like the
central african republic are today some
of the poorest in the world in part due
to the legacies of french-backed
dictators like jean bedell bokassa but
there's another aspect of french
influence it's even more important
probably the most central part of all is
the cfa franc the last colonial currency
still in widespread use
in practice the countries that use the
cfa franc have virtually no monetary
sovereignty the value of their currency
is linked to the euro
the poorest countries in the world have
a currency controlled by the richest
countries and so the imperatives of
european countries fiscal discipline and
fighting inflation end up shaping the
very different world of western and
central africa
that leads to an overly tight approach
to credit something that's necessary in
our current system for an economy to
grow
it means that any appreciation in the
euro makes exports from these countries
less price competitive
so just look at what happened in senegal
when the euro appreciated against the
dollar from 2000 to 2009 the value of
the cfa franc got higher but this made
local senegalese rice more expensive
than imported rice from thailand so
senegal which was trying to build its
own domestic rice industry instead saw
thai rice wipe out local rice farmers so
because domestic products are expensive
this makes export-driven growth nearly
impossible which is necessary to lead a
country out of poverty
that's why most countries that use a cfa
franc have growth rates significantly
lower than their neighbors
because the cfa discourages the
development of domestic industry many of
these economies have actually been
shrinking
the ivory coast the largest cfa frank
country has a real gdp per capita
one-third lower than it had in 1978.
other cfa franc countries like cameroon
and the republic of the congo reached
their highest levels of real gdp per
capita in the 70s and 80s and because
economic growth is weaker there's more
incentive for local elites in these
countries always tied closely to french
multinationals to take as much money out
as possible
billions of dollars have flooded out of
these countries and into shell
corporations and foreign bank accounts
through massive corruption these african
aliens have joined the ranks of the
global super-rich
in 2007 for example
omar bongo's daughter-in-law appeared on
vh1 to buy an la mansion for 25 million
dollars
and elites in france get a great deal
too they enjoy cheap access to natural
resources and kickbacks from shady
business deals a french billionaire
named vincent bolare now owns most of
the major ports across west africa in
france bola ray is known as the quote
king of africa
so french colonialism in africa has
never really ended this is why academics
used the term
neo-colonialism even as the branding of
empire has faded away the structures of
economic extraction have only grown
stronger this neocolonialism is actually
a much more efficient form of
exploitation than the colonialism of the
past the french no longer pretend to
care about building functional
governments or improving local living
standards it's pure extraction all the
time so these african countries are not
underdeveloped they're over exploited
france is almost totally reliant on its
influence in africa for its economic
power
in the words of italy's foreign minister
if france didn't have its african
colonies because that's what they should
be called it would be the 15th largest
world economy instead it's among the
first exactly because of what it's doing
in africa
and the french know this francois
mitterrand former president of france
said it himself without africa he
declared france will have no history in
the 21st century
today of course france faces competition
from china within africa and new
challenges to the colonial symbolism of
the cfa franc there are plans to change
the currency's name and abandon the most
overt symbols of the colonial past to
make it look like the system is more
african than french
but france has no intention of actually
abandoning our system of extraction that
has made it one of the richest nations
on earth the real question is whether
the next generation of africans will
allow it to continue
i'm miss my ludvi for the gravel
institute
[Music]
[Music]
you